federal investigators say Patek had
devices on also at least 12 of those
guns in the room that allowed him to
mimic fully automatic weapons they're
called bump fire stocks their devices
that allow rifles to fire rapidly and
they're completely legal in an interview
you'll see only on CBS this morning
DeMarco Morgan spoke to the manager of
the last gun store paddock is believed
to have visited DeMarco is outside that
store in Mesquite Nevada where 80 miles
that's about 80 miles from here in Las
Vegas DeMarco good morning good morning
Nora Nevada does not require gun
licenses or registrations so here you
can own as many firearms as you want the
general manager of guns and guitars says
he sold fatica weapon just days before
the massacre
I was ill you know made me physically
ill to think that we had interacted with
him and he had committed such a tragedy
general manager Christopher Sullivan
told us he sold a Steven paddock a rifle
on September 28th the same day police
say paddock checked into the Mandalay
Bay Hotel felony gilt abode I don't know
we do everything right we can't control
what someone does once they leave this
store Sullivan told us panic had been a
customer of guns and guitars for about a
year and in that time the shop sold him
five of firearms just knowing that this
may have been his last two stop before
heading to Las Vegas does that make you
feel some type of way sort of
responsible this morning over coffee I
was having a moment in myself thinking
that I may have very well been the last
person to shake hands with that man
vadik fired into a Las Vegas crowd
Sunday night and what sounded like
automatic rounds the ETF says panic had
24 guns in his hotel room and 12 of them
had bump fire stocks the devices are
attached to the back of rifles bumpier
stocks allow squeezed triggers to slide
back and forth more quickly simulate an
automatic fire that these bump stocks
are basically a workaround that allow
people to take a gun that's perfectly
legal and turn them into something
equivalent to a machine gun
UCLA law professor Adam Winkler says if
there is gun reform it could involve
regulation of modification device
is like bonfire stocks I think that's
the kind of regulation that the NRA may
support there's a broad consensus even
among gun owners that people shouldn't
have access to automatic fire weapons
banning these devices is a way of
banning automatic fire weapons a guns
and guitars tells us it did not sell
panic any ammunition or bump fire stocks
at another store in North Las Vegas
where patek purchase weapons says it did
all the proper background checks and did
not sell them any automatic weapons nor
all right DeMarco thank you so much for
your reporting